[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris einen schönen guten abend
wünsche ich ihnen und sie haben es
geschafft die deutschen fußball-frauen
gestern abend norbert sieg im finale
gegen frankreich und jetzt der neunten
titel zum greifen nah wahnsinn läuft das
sind unsere großen themen heute
das wird noch teurer ab oktober sollen
gaskunden eine umlage zahlen
wirtschaftsminister habe rechnet mit
mehreren hundert euro pro haushalt
leben auf pump noch nie zuvor hat die
menschheit die ressourcen der erde so
früh aufgebracht wie in diesem jahr und
das traumfinale ist perfekt nach dem 2
zu 1 gegen frankreich stehen die
deutschen frauen im em endspiel gegen
england
wer mit gas heizt wird ab oktober noch
tiefer in die tasche greifen müssen denn
ab dann müssen alle eine gas umlage
zahlen für die nächsten anderthalb jahre
das heißt konkret auf jede
kilowattstunde kommen eineinhalb bis
fünf cent drauf die genaue summe soll
mitte bis ende august feststehen am ende
könnte das pro jahr mehrere 100 euro
zusätzlich bedeuten mehr dazu von frank
buchwald
hohe besuch im heizungskeller hessens
wirtschaftsminister zu gast bei familie
kirberg in idstein es geht ums
energiesparen heizen wird erheblich
teurer so viel ist klar im oktober kommt
noch eine umlage obendrauf schwer zu
kalkulieren für maja und daniel kirberg
das scheint natürlich erstmal sehr
großes paket was da auf uns zukommt und
ob das dann tatsächlich somit im sinne
des verbrauchers dann am ende ist weiß
ich nicht sowie comebacks geht es allen
die mit gas heizen in deutschland
immerhin jeder zweite auch der
vizekanzler kann bisher nicht sagen wie
viel die umlage genau ausmacht billig
aber wird das nicht wir rechnen damit
dass es zwischen 1,5 bis 5 cent pro
kilowattstunde sein wird und dann muss
man ein bisschen rechnen wenn der
durchschnittliche verbrauch bei 20.000
kilowattstunden liegt landet man in
einen mittleren 100 euro bereich grund
russland liefert kaum noch gas
langfristige verträge platzen versorger
wie juniper müssen nun ersatz mengen
besorgen x-mal teurer vielen stadtwerken
droht die pleite
die umlage soll sie nun retten die
opposition warnt vor sozialen
schieflagen wir brauchen jetzt eine
konkrete initiative der bundesregierung
um gezielt menschen mit kleinen und
mittleren einkommen besser zu helfen
nicht nur denjenigen die wohngeld
empfang viele mieter zahlen schon jetzt
sehr viel höhere heizkosten durch die
umlage dürfte diese belastung weiter
steigen
heute ist es so dass wir wissen dass am
ersten zehn gas anlage kommt und die
veröffentlichung der gaspreiserhöhung
die im august in aussicht gestellt wird
würden wir deswegen gerne abwarten das
war greift der bund vielen menschen
finanziell unter die arme stichwort
energie geld oder wohngeld
verbraucherschützer aber wollen mehr
wenn die umlage zum ersten oktober kommt
dann muss auch dann das hilfspaket für
diejenigen stehen die eben eigentlich so
dicken geldbeutel haben und damit sie
auch gut über den winter kommen wurden
nicht billig in deutschland absehbar
dürfte es noch teurer werden sozialer
sprengstoff selbst in einem reichen land
und die inflation in deutschland ist im
juli den zweiten monat in folge leicht
zurückgegangen waren und
dienstleistungen kosteten
durchschnittlich siebeneinhalb prozent
mehr als ein jahr zuvor teilte das
statistische bundesamt mit schuld sind
weiterhin vor allem teure lebensmittel
und die hohen energiekosten
da lässt aufhorchen dass heute gleich
mehrere energiekonzerne deutliche
gewinne im ersten halbjahr vermeldeten
gemacht zu stefanie bald an die
frankfurter börse stefanie woran liegt
das also die mineralölgesellschaften
zählen insbesondere seitdem ukraine
krieg zu den großen krisengewinnern und
sie machen ordentlich kasse denn
russisches öl ist wegen der sanktionen
knapper geworden das hat die ölpreis am
weltmarkt nach oben getrieben auch die
gewinnspannen der raffinerien sind
gestiegen weil viele in den letzten
jahren geschlossen wurden man wollte ja
weg von fossilen energieträgern
und vor allem verdienen die multi es
ganz gewaltig an ihrem eigenen handel
mit strom und gas allein in den
vergangenen monaten an den drei monaten
verdoppelten sich die gewinne von
europas größtem ölkonzern shell im
vergleich zum vorjahr ebenso wie die des
französischen energieriesen total energy
und des spanischen ölmultis repsol kein
zweifel die mineralölkonzerne verdienen
prächtig das dürfte die debatte um eine
beteiligung der ölmultis an der
entlastung von industrie und
verbrauchern in deutschland wieder
befeuern einige europäische länder
schöpfen nämlich bereits über
sondersteuern gewinne ab andere planen
es denn die eu-kommission hat immerhin
bereits grünes licht gegeben für eine
solche zeitlich begrenzte über gewinn
steuer dankeschön stefan die welt
quasi von einem tag auf den anderen hat
das wirtschaftsministerium die regeln
geändert was wie bei gebäudesanierungen
finanziell gefördert wird in einigen
fällen gilt das bereits ab heute bei
einzelnen maßnahmen wie dem austausch
von fenstern ab dem 15 august durch die
bank wurden die fördersätze gekürzt das
argument dadurch sollen mehr leute
profitieren
der grund für die kürzungen knappe
haushaltsmittel es gibt breite kritik
sven regn berichtet henning ballmann
installiert mit seinen leuten derzeit
fast nur wärmepumpen der immens
steigende gaspreis und die hohe
förderung haben die nachfrage
explodieren lassen doch jetzt ist klar
für den einbau von wärmepumpen gibt es
weniger geld das könnte so manche
bauherren treffen dass der teilweise bis
zu 20 prozent wegfallen an förderung die
er sicherlich auch kalkuliert sind um
überhaupt diese kosten der investition
aufzufangen wenn die fehlen wird aus
einigen sicherlich den umbaukosten nicht
nur bei wärmepumpen kürzt die
bundesregierung für den einbau neuer
fenster etwa gibt es statt 25 nur noch
20 prozent vom staat pro wohnung im
höchstfall 3000 euro weniger die
insgesamt 14 milliarden euro sollen so
für mehr einzelmaßnahmen reichen lautet
die begründung die im umweltschutz so
die kritik hilft das aber wenig wir
brauchen klimaziel kompatibel sanierung
und eine höhere sanierungsrate aber was
wir de facto gerade sehen ist eine
absenkung der fördermittel damit
verfehlen wir weiterhin kinder ziele die
wir schon in den letzten jahren im
gebäudesektor verfehlt haben schon die
dritte änderung bei den förderungen
dieses jahr jedes mal müssen die
unternehmen neu kalkulieren jedesmal
verteuern sich die maßnahmen durch
stetig steigende materialkosten und
zinsen um wirklich nachhaltig zu
sanieren bräuchte es so die berechnungen
der branche ohnehin 100 milliarden euro
pro jahr und wenn sie dann diese
förderung dagegen setzte wo ich sagen ja
ist doch gut wenn die mehreren zugute
kommt dann sind das ungefähr zwei
prozent
aber die anderen 93 prozent die muss ja
irgendjemand bezahlen und die werden am
ende in den wohnkosten lang wärmepumpen
fachmann ballmann sieht noch ein problem
beim energetischen sanieren die
lieferzeiten kunden die heute bei ihm
eine wärmepumpe bestellen müssen derzeit
ein halbes jahr warten tendenz stark
steigend
in die ukraine während das land seinen
tag der eigenstaatlichkeit begeht greift
die russische armee weiter genau diese
ukrainische eigenstaatlichkeit an heute
wurden dabei erstmals seit wochen erneut
die region kirow sharif im norden des
landes bombardiert wie gefährlich die
lage ist auch an orten an denen wieder
die ukrainische armee das sagen hat
berichtet franziska von tiesenhausen
was die russische armee innerhalb von
sechs monaten hier in sumy im nordosten
des landes angerichtet hat zeigt die
ukrainische nationalgarde unserem
kamerateam bei einer geführten
pressetour im april haben sich russlands
truppen zurückgezogen gefährlich ist es
aber nach wie vor nicht nur wegen der
minen sondern auch weil die region immer
wieder beschossen wird auch deshalb
spricht präsident sie lenski seinen
landsleuten am heutigen tag der
eigenstaatlichkeit mut zu
wir werden kämpfen und wir werden leben
wir werden nicht aufgeben bis wir den
letzten besatzer aus unserem land
getrieben haben
zielinski zur folge hat die ukraine die
kontrolle über 20 prozent ihres
territoriums verloren doch im süden
gewinnt eine gegenoffensive auf die
besetzte stadt ressort britischen
verteidigungsministerium an sprung unter
anderem seien in der nähe der stadt drei
brücken beschädigt worden auf die
russland angewiesen ist um seine truppen
zu versorgen durch diese angriffe soll
person vom rest der besetzten gebiete so
gut wie abgeschnitten seien die
russische seite weist das zurück
das wird uns nicht aufhalten diese
zerstörung bringt nichts und beweist
nicht dass diese nazis nachher sohn
vordringen werden
besetzt ist die stadt schon seit märz
die eingesetzte militärverwaltung will
im september ein referendum über den
beitritt zur russischen föderation
abhalten die ukrainische seite will das
verhindern und
wir kommen zurück nach deutschland
im juni 2009 10 wurde der kasseler
regierungspräsident walter lübcke von
rechtsextremisten stefan ernst ermordet
ernst wurde zu lebenslanger haft
verurteilt
der zweite angeklagte markus h ebenfalls
ein rechtsextremist wurde vom vorwurf
der beihilfe freigesprochen
alle seiten legten revision ein das
urteil wird jetzt vom bundesgerichtshof
auf rechtsfehler überprüft seine attacke
und christoph schneider berichten
schwerer gang für familie lücke zum bgh
noch mal geht es um die ermordung des
ehemanns und vaters vor anderthalb
jahren wurde der rechtsextremist stefan
ernst wegen mordes an walter lübke zu
lebenslanger haft verurteilt die
sicherungsverwahrung behält das gericht
vor für die frankfurter richterinnen und
richter stand fest dass ernst alleine
anfang juni 2009 10 walter lübcke auf
der terrasse seines hauses in nordhessen
heimtückisch erschossen getrieben von
rassistischen und fremdenfeindlichen
motiven
neben ernst wurde der mitangeklagte
markus zahno wegen unerlaubten
waffenbesitzes verurteilt obwohl ihn die
bundesanwaltschaft wegen beihilfe zum
mord angeklagte für familie lübke ist
besonders dieses milde urteil nicht
nachvollziehbar dass mehrere fehler
enthalte erstens darstellungs lücken
eklatante darstellungs lücken im
schriftlichen urteil standen die
anwendung einer falschen weiß regel und
drittens eine fehlende praktisch
komplett fehlende gesamtwürdigung
emotional wurde es während der
verhandlungen als sich die witwe von
walter lübke an das gericht wenden mit
tränen in den augen hat sie beschrieben
die man ja immer gesagt habe dass er
froh sei in einem land zu leben in dem
land frei seine meinung äußern kann und
dass genau diese überzeugung am ende
ihrem mann das leben gekostet habe das
zeigt nochmal welche immense
gesellschaftliche dimension dieses
verfahren hat eine entscheidung des
höchsten deutschen strafgerichts über
die revisionsanträge wird in der august
erwartet die
deutsche bahn schreibt wieder schwarze
zahlen in der halbjahresbilanz wird
schnell klar woran das vor allem liegt
die international agierende
logistiktochter schenker spürte einen
milliarden-gewinn in die kasse
insgesamt machte die bahn in den ersten
sechs monaten einen gewinn von rund
876 millionen euro beim umsatz von fast
28 milliarden euro im personenverkehr
gibt es noch erhebliche probleme auch
wenn die zahl der fahrgäste wieder
gestiegen ist haben sie ein tier
berichtet
die fahrgäste sind wieder zurück volle
züge und bahnsteige nicht nur dank neun
euro ticket im regio sondern auch
intercity und ece fast 60 millionen
reisende seit januar fast so viele wie
vor der pandemie für den bahnchef eine
trendwende wir lassen langsam aber
sicher diese corona pandemie und die
finanziellen anschläge die ja durchaus
dramatisch waren hinter uns und sehen
dass die menschen wieder zurückkommen in
der system und wir eben nach vorne
betrachtet weiter auch profitabel
wachsen können mehr fahrgäste obwohl die
pünktlichkeit auf einen tiefstand
gesunken ist fast jeder zweite fernzug
kam im juni mehr als sechs minuten zu
spät hauptgrund noch nie wurde so viel
am schienennetz gebaut zerschlissene
fahrwege veraltete technik über jahre
vernachlässigt sondern alles jetzt in
einem kraftakt fit für doppelt so viele
fahrgäste ab 2030 werden zeitweise auf
über 850 baustellen pro tag und das ist
erst der anfang ab nächstem jahr sollen
die arbeiten gebündelt werden was
bedeutet hauptstrecken auch für längere
zeit zu sperren die probleme haben sich
über 20 jahre aufgestaut und hatte 20
jahre vor sich hergeschoben und jetzt
das netz zu sanieren wird jahre dauern
und wir müssen uns auf jahre einrichten
in denen die pünktlichkeit nicht besser
wird und in denen also er nochmal
verbindungen gestrichen werden um das
netz überhaupt zu stabilisieren keine
guten nachrichten für bahnkunden
die gerade jetzt in scharen zurück
kommen
von heute an lebt die menschheit bei der
natur auf pump das ist die botschaft des
sogenannten ehrt überlastung ska bis
aufs jahr gesehen sind heute weltweit
alle natürlichen ressourcen verbraucht
die unser planet ersetzen kann in vielen
industrieländern lag der errechnete tag
sogar schon früher bei uns in
deutschland zum beispiel am vierten mai
damit sich der trend endlich ändert
setzen forschende auf einfallsreiche
lösungen makko mit einem beispiel aus
der landwirtschaft
dieser apfel ist etwas besonderes er ist
teil einer idee durch die schon bald
ressourcen gespart werden könnten in dem
fall guter boden die idee ist eigentlich
einfach oben erzeugen solarzellen strom
unten wächst obst sowie auf dieser
versuchsanlage in gehlsdorf in der eifel
wir profitieren hier von dieser
doppelnutzung dh die landwirtschaftliche
fläche bleibt erhalten die ungemein
wertvoll ist und die man eigentlich viel
zu wenig schätzt aber trotzdem haben wir
die möglichkeit solarstrom zu erzeugen
der uns für die bewirtschaftung anfällt
an zur verfügung steht
erneuerbarer strom der hilft kohle und
gas zu sparen und es gibt noch einen
vorteil das solardach schützt vor sonne
starkregen und hagel trotzdem nicht jede
apfelsorte ist dafür geeignet es gibt
noch forschungsbedarf wir wissen ja dass
die kulturen unterschiedlich anfällig
sind für reduktionen was den licht
anfang an geht aber auch eben auf die
bemessung durch den regen und deshalb
wollen wir einfach schauen welche von
diesen acht hob sorten hier am besten
für diese art der photovoltaik
das ist grundsätzlich klappt es da schon
bewiesen das modell ist teil der
solaroffensive der bundesregierung und
wird ab dem kommenden jahr gefördert für
landwirte kann sich das doppelt lohnen
für die natur außerdem
schauen wir auf die waldbrände in
deutschland im süden brandenburgs war
das feuer zwischenzeitlich unter
kontrolle aber aufflammende glutnester
halten die einsatzkräfte weiter in atem
schlimmer sieht es in sachsen aus in der
sächsischen schweiz haben sich die
brände noch ausgeweitet in der nacht war
ein weiteres feuer von tschechien aus
über die grenze gekommen cornelia
schiemenz berichtet über den kampf gegen
die flammen
erst aus der luft wird das ganze ausmaß
der katastrophe sichtbar
es sind viele vereinzelte brände immer
wieder neu angefacht durch den wind in
den zerklüfteten tälern der sächsischen
schweiz ist das löschen der brände eine
mammut aufgabe
zu helfen es sind sowohl zivile
hubschrauber als auch unterstützung
seitens der bundeswehr und das ist
dringend nötig um den brand unter
kontrolle
sachsens innenminister hat seinen urlaub
abgebrochen ist angesichts der flammen
mitten im nationalpark geschockt und
verspricht umfangreiche hilfe jedenfalls
werden wir
alles was sachsen kann
an ressourcen hier rein werfen wir
werden es schaffen aber es wird nicht so
kurz gehen wie mancher vermutet hunderte
feuerwehrleute kämpfen bis zur
erschöpfung gegen die flammen
unterstützt von den löschhubschraubern
die elbe führte moment extremes
niedrigwasser tschechien hat deshalb
heute staustufen im elb oberlauf
geöffnet so fließt mehr wasser die elbe
hinunter wasser das so dringend zum
löschen benötigt wird
ja viele millionen menschen am gestern
es gleich gemacht gestern abend zwar das
grandiose halbfinale geguckt und das
daumendrücken hat geklappt deutschland
steht die entfernen und zwar so was von
verdient eine taktische meisterleistung
gegen starke französin ein toller
teamgeist ja und vor allem eine
überragende kapitän in die beide treffer
erzielte alexandra popp deutschland darf
vom 9 titelträume noch bei ankunft am
neuen quartier heute nachmittag
schwärmen alle von alexandra popp sonst
sehr sehr starkes turnier zu spielen ist
wirklich sehr krass und hilft uns
natürlich enorm fast erdrückt wird die
superhelden gestern nach abpfiff von
ihren teamkolleginnen alexandra popp
total erschöpft aber überglücklich ihr 1
0 in der 40 minute mit dem starken
linken fuß bringt ihr team nur fünf
minuten lang in führung dennoch vor der
pause gelingt die ja nie über den
pfosten und dem rücken von torf auf roms
der ausgleich der hat bis zur 76 minute
bestand dann fliegt pop kopf voran dem
ball entgegen 2 1 finale gegen england
in wembley erreicht
53 siege viermal weltmeister
und jetzt ist feierabend sebastian
vettel einer der erfolgreichsten
rennfahrer der formel-1-geschichte
beendet seine großartige karriere nach
dieser saison der 35 jährige will mehr
zeit für seine familie haben wie ein
außerirdischer vettel in seinem
heimatort heppenheim auf dem gipfel
seiner karriere ein jahrzehnt ist das
nun her mit der formel 1 zurück zu
widmen wie ich es in der vergangenheit
getan habe wie ich es für richtig halte
und ein guter vater und ehemann zu sein
passend für mich nicht mehr zusammen die
jahre bei red bull bringen vier
titelgewinne in folge als sportler des
jahres zeigt vettel seine wurzeln doch
wieder bei ferrari noch bei aston martin
kann er die erfolge wiederholen
zunehmend rücken außer sportliche
aspekte in vettels blickfeld er
engagiert sich für klimaschutz und
menschenrechte
formel 1 fahrer zu sein bringt dinge mit
sich die mir nicht mehr gefallen der
familie gehört bald die größte
aufmerksamkeit für sebastian vettel gibt
es ein leben neben der strecke
foto de france der frauen da hat die
niederländische radrennfahrerin lorena
wie es ihren zweiten tagessieg gefeiert
die 23 jährige gewann nach
175,6 km überlegen im massensprint
ja aber auch bei dieser fünften etappe
setzte sich die serie schwerer unfälle
vor 45 kilometer vor dem ziel kam es im
feld zu einem massensturz ja wieder gab
es verletzte und für zwei fahrerinnen
ist die tour definitiv vorbei menschen
mehr gute schnelle besserung so norbert
zumblick noch kurz aufs wetter
trockenheit und dürre begleiten uns ja
durch diesen sommer aber und das ist
jetzt die gute nachricht heute nacht und
morgen soll es endlich regnen die
einzelheiten hat gleich katja hornuf für
sie christian sievers begrüßt sie um 21
45 zum heute schon ein auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend wer sich nach regen sind der
hat sich heute wahrscheinlich schon über
feuchte luft gefreut und über wolken
hier an der küste und jetzt kommen immer
mehr wolken hier von süden und südwesten
heran so gewittert es aus den alpen
heraus in der nacht bereits und in der
zweiten nachthälfte ziehen regenschauer
und gewitter auch über dem schwarzwald
weiter richtung odenwald spessart rhön
und später dann auch ins sauerland hier
im norden bleibt es dagegen zum teil
klar oder nur locker bewölkt dort wird
auch am kühlsten mit tiefsttemperaturen
zwischen 13 und 8 grad sonst geht's auf
16 bis 13 grad rotter und morgen liegen
die höchsttemperaturen an der
nordseeküste bei 20 22 grad sonst werden
23 bis 30 grad erreicht und hier in
diesem bereich bleibt es auch ein
bisschen kühler das liegt dort an den
dichteren wolken da regnet es häufiger
und es sind auch gewitter dabei am
nachmittag kann es dann aus den alpen
neue kräftige gewitter geben die können
dann auch unwettercharakter haben also
vor allen dingen starkregen mitbringen
dann lockern die wolken hier am
oberrhein schon wieder auch und etwa
nördlich von hannover und berlin wird es
freundlich war am samstag verlassen uns
regenschauer und gewitter ostwärts am
sonntag gibt's neue schauer und gewitter
von nordwesten und in der neuen woche
steigen die temperaturen häufiger wieder
über 30 grad genannt